how is your Batmobile different well I
mean I think that well first of all when
they say like oh when we were working on
the movie and we were like okay we're
gonna put Batman in the movie it's
that's cool I said we need a Batmobile
right because if you're a smallest
amount of a dork you want to make a
Batmobile alright like that seems like a
that seems like the first thing you want
to do so I think the cool thing that we
try to do I mean you've seen the Chris
Nolan Batman movies and they used the
tumbler is a you know they they they
repurposed a military vehicle yes so the
cool thing about the our Batmobile is
its purpose built by Bruce Wayne to be
the Batmobile allows it to be a slightly
Battier sure yeah yeah so it's got more
back like that well no that was Batman
saying yeah
I'm auditioning by the way so wait so
you're a Batmobile it's Bruce Wayne made
it for himself it's not something he was
meant for the military and also you've
made it so that it can really be driven
is that right no absolutely well I drove
in it yep I know sometimes a car like
that can be driven like a block no no on
and then the prop guys come in and the
technicians say don't touch it by the
way wait we have a grid there was a bit
in the movie where Superman stands on
the Batmobile right yeah and you know
they'd finish it they're like oh my gosh
look it's an amazing look exact here it
is and I was like wow it looks great
it's looks like a real car and they're
like yeah and I'm like it'll be cool and
Superman stands on and they're like no
mm no no we can stand on it right that's
like it's made of chocolates it's nada
it's literally like guys it's gotta and
I started to walk on and they're like no
no don't do that so they had to
reinforce it and they like to filled it
with foam and stuff like that's a good
fan i but you know worked out with it it
worked out really great now Christian
Bale apparently gave Ben Affleck advice
about playing Batman what was his advice
the advice was
and clearly that comes from one actor to
another and it was to make sure they put
a zipper in the suit or yeah which was a
thing of course I didn't think of you
know I'm I'm I probably was like why is
there a seam there there should be no
seam you're like Zach the guy has to
urinate
yeah oh my god yeah that's not my
problem make a real make a real Batman
just pees in the suit that's like a wet
suit right what I'd have done if you had
given me the part if it was told we got
him for the whole night yes if he seems
from like wait a minute Joker and then I
just stand there for a minute
don't talk don't talk don't look at me
Joker turn around look that way okay
here we go